مشاهدينا ننتقل الان الى الرياض ومتابعه
لانطلاق اعمال مؤتمر رجال الاعمال العرب
والصيني والسلام على خاتم الانبياء
والمرسلين
معالي نائب رئيس المؤتمر الاستشاري
السياسي للشعب الصيني معاني الامين العام
لجامعه الدول العربيه
اصحاب السمو اصحاب المعالي والسعاده
الحضور الكريم السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
يطيب لي في البدايه انقل لكم تحيات سيدي
صاحب السمو الملكي امير محمد بن سلمان ابن
عبد العزيز ولي العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء
حفظ الله في افتتاح الدوره العاشر لمؤتمر
رجال الاعمال العرب والصينيون عشرون ثلاثه
وعشرون هذا الحدث الاقتصادي الكبير الذي
تستضيفه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
تحت شعار التعاون من اجل الازدهار وبرعايه
كريمه من سموه والتي تنبع من اهتمامه حفظ
الله وحرصه على الرفع من مستوى العمل
للخروج بنتائج تليق بالشراكه العريقه
والمتقدمه في جميع المجالات الاستثماريه
الحيويه بين الدول العربيه وجمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه كما اعبر لكم عن بالغه سروري
وترحيب بكم جميعا وتمنياتي
الصادقه بني يحقق هذا المؤتمر النتائج
المرجوه باذن الله
انه لمن الملهم ان نرى مثل هذا التجمع
المتميز من المسؤولين والخبراء وصناع
القرار من اشقائنا واصدقائنا من الدول
العربيه وجمهوريه الصين الشعبيه هنا في
عاصمه المملكه العربيه السعوديه الرياض
منطلقين نحو تعزيز التواصل فيما بيننا
والذي تمتد على مدى قرون من الزمن على
الرغم من البعد الجغرافي
مما اثرت تعارف وزاد من الثقه المتبادره
بين الشعوب العربيه والشعب الصيني وعزز
التبادل التجاري والتواصل الحضاري وقدموا
مساهمه مهمه في التطور والتقدم للبشريه
وسجل فصلا رائعا في تاريخ التواصل الحضاري
العالمي حضور الكريم ان اجتماعنا اليوم
يعد فرصه للعمل على تعزيز وتكريس الصداقه
العربيه الصينيه التاريخيه والعمل على
بناء مستقبل مشترك نحو عصر جديد يعود
بالخير على شعوبنا ويحافظ على السلام
والتنميه في العالم
الحضور الكريم يؤكد موضوع مؤتمر اليوم
التعاون من اجل الرخاء على اهميه البالغه
والامكانات الكبيره والرؤى المشتركه التي
تكمن في العلاقات الاستثماريه التجاريه
بين العالم العربي والصين
ويسلط الضوء على كيفيه التوافق المشترك
وتبادل الخبرات واطلاق فرص الجديده للنمو
والاستثمار والتي من شانها تحقيق الرخاء
والتقدم والازدهار للشعوب المنطقه والعالم
وفي هذا السياق اود ان ارحب بالنتائج
المثمره التي حققها منتدى التعاون العربي
الصيني منذ تاسيسه لكافه المجالات
ومساهمته في توطيد الصداقه العربيه
الصينيه التاريخيه وتعزيز الثقه السياسيه
المتبادله والحوار والتعاون بين الجانبين
كما اشاهد بالنتائج الايجابيه التي حققتها
اليات التعاون في اطار منتدى التعاون
العربي الصيني في سبيل تعزيز العلاقات
العربيه الصينيه والفعاليات التي عقدت
واخرتها الدور الثامنه عشر لاجتماع كبار
المسؤولين لمنتدى التعاون العربي الصيني
والدوره السابعه للحوار السياسي
الاستراتيجي والتي انعقدت في مدينه
الصينيه في شهر مايو 23 اصحاب السمو
والمعالي والسعاده ان زياره التاريخيه
الناجحه لفخامه الرئيس الصيني
الى الرياض في ديسمبر 2020
زادت من توطيد الروابط بين البلدين
الصديقين في كافه المجالات سواء السياسيه
او الاقتصاديه او الاستثماريه والتجاريه
والتي تزامنت مع اطلاق اول قمه عربيه
صينيه وقمه خليجيه صينيه والتي اثمرت
جميعها عن توقيع العديد من الاتفاقيات
ومذكرات التفاهم بقيمه تجاوزت 50 مليون
دولار
مجموعه من القطاعات المختلفه كمن الصين
تعد الشريك التجاري الاكبر للدول العربيه
حيث بلغ اجمالي حجم التبادل التجاري بين
الجانبين
430 مليار دولار في العام 20 22
بمعدل لنمو بلغ واحد وثلاثون في المئه
مقارنه بالعام 20 21 وتمثل المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ما نسبته 25% من اجمالي
التبادل التجاري بين الصين والدول العربيه
حيث بلغ حجم التبادل التجاري بين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وجمهوريه الصين الشعبيه
106 مليار دولار في عام 2022 بمعدل زياده
بلغ 30% مقارنه بالعام 20 21
ان نفخوني بما حققته الشراكه فيما بيننا
حتى الان وما يدفعنا اكثر لتعزيز هذه
الشراكه هي الرغبه المتبادله من الجانبين
في تطوير وتوسيع وتنميه حجم الاعمال
والشراكات من خلال الربط والمؤامى بينما
تمتلكه منطقه العربيه من ثروات طبيعيه
وامكانات بشريه وتطلعات طموحه نحو تطوير
بيئتنا الاستثماريه الخصبه وما تمتلكه
الصين من تقنيات وخبرات رائده على المستوى
العالمي تمكننا من النهوض باقتصاداتنا
وبناء مستقبل مشرق لاجيالنا القادمه
الاخوه والاخوات الكرام خلال هذا الحدث
نامل ان نستفيد جميعا من الحضور الكبيره
للقطاع الخاص العربي والصيني في مشاركه
الفرص الاستثماريه النوعيه في كافه
المجالات الاقتصاديه واستغلال المناقشات
الهادفه والحوارات النيره في الموضوعات
المختلفه التي سيتم عرضها عبر جلسات هذا
المؤتمر ورش عمله والتي يشارك فيها نخبه
عالميون من ابرز المفكرين وصناع القرار
ورجال وسيدات الاعمال وكل امل ايضا ان
يكتسب ضيوفنا الصينيون رؤيه قيمه حول فرص
الاستثمارات الضخمه في منطقتنا العربيه في
شتى المجالات
ختاما اعبر اعرب مره اخرى عن خالص
امتينيات امتناني وتقديري وشكري للجميع
الحاضرين على انضمامهم الينا اليوم في هذا
الهدف العالمي المتميز امنين ان يخرج
اجتماعنا هذا من نتائج موفقه تصب في تعزيز
علاقات التعاون العربي الصينيه وتحقيق
المصالح المشتركه والمنافع المتبادله
متمنيا لكم جميعا مشاركه ممتعه ونجاح دائم
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا كلنا معكم في متابعه لكلمه وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان
من خلال اعماله انطلاق اعمال مؤتمر الرجال
الاعمال العرب والصينيين في نسخته العاشره
وزير الخارجي السعودي مشاهدينا كما تابعنا
قال ان هناك رغبه متبادله بين الدول
العربيه والصين لتطوير الشراكه والتعاون
وقال ايضا ان الصين تعد الشركه التجاريه
الاكبر للدول العربيه
ب430 مليار دولار اضاف ايضا وزير خارجيه
السعودي بان زياره الرئيس الصيني للرياض
زادت من توطيد العلاقات الثنائيه وكذلك
قال ان مؤتمر الاعمال فرصه لتعزيز الصداقه
العربيه الصينيه
عايزين معكم اذا مشاهدينا في متابعه لهذه
انطلاقه اعمال الدوره العاشره لاعمال
المؤتمر رجاء العرب الصيني والان معنا او
نتابع هذه الكلمه للسيد احمد ابو الغيط
الامين العام جامعه الدول العربيه
معالي المهندس خالد بن عبد العزيز الفالح
وزير الاستثمار بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه
معالي السيد خوتشوان
او هو
نائب رئيس الهيئه الاستشاريه السياسيه
بجمهوريه الصين الشعبيه
اصحاب السمو والمعالي
وهناك الكثير من الساده الوزراء
والشخصيات الكبيره التي لها احترامها في
هذا المجال
حضور الكريم
انه من دواعي السرور ان اشارككم اليوم
افتتاح اعمال الدوره العاشره لمؤتمر رجال
الاعمال العرب والصينيين
والدوره الثامنه لندوه الاستثمارات
تحت شعار التعاون من اجل الرخاء
برعايه كريمه من صاحب السمو الملكي الامير
محمد بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال سعود ولي
العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء
واسمحوا لي ان اتقدم بخالص الشكر والتقدير
لمعالي المهندس خالد بن عبد العزيز الفالح
والى فريقه على جهودهم لحسن الاعداد لهذه
الفعاليه وحرصهم على التنسيق مع الامانه
العامه للجامعه العربيه
وكافه الشركاء
لاخراجها بالشكل اللائق
واثني على كرم الضيافه وحسن الوفاده الذي
احطنا به
احاطتنا به المملكه منذ ان وطات اقدامنا
هذه الارض الطيبه المقدسه
سيدات والساده من استضافه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
التي اذكر من هذا المقام انها تقود دفه
العمل العربيه المشترك للفتره القادمه منذ
تراسها للقمه العربيه بجده في 19 مايو
الماضي الماضي اقول ان استضافتها لهذه
الفعاليه تاتي استكمالا لجهودها الناجحه
في احتضان اول قمه عربيه صينيه عقدت هنا
في الرياض في 9
ديسمبر 2022
وهي قمه اعطت مخرجاتها دفعه جديده للتعاون
العربي الصيني في كافه المجالات السياسيه
والاقتصاديه والثقافيه
بفضل رغبه الطرفين الصادقه في الارتقاء
بالتعاون الى رحاب اوسع واشكرك جمهوريه
الصين الشعبيه على ما تفجيه من اهتمام
دائم وحرص بالغ لتعزيز علاقات الصداقه
والتبادل في جو من الاحترام والثقه
والتكافؤ
وغني عن البيان ان العلاقات العربيه
الصينيه الممتده
ممتده في الحقيقه عبر التاريخ وضاربه في
اعماقه فهي علاقات بين شعبين لهما حضرات
شهدت تبادلا مستمرا الى اليوم
وقد شكل هذا التواصل رصيدا مشتركا من
التفاهم
ورغبه قويه لدى الطرفين العربي والصيني
للبناء عليه
وتوسعه الى مجالات جديده
وها نحن اليوم نسهم في كتابه احدى صفحات
ذلك التعاون الذي اثق في انه سوف يزداد
متانه وثراء في ظل معنا
وفي هذا الشان اذكر ايضا بان اليه مؤتمر
رجال الاعمال العرب والصينيين التي نجتمع
اليوم في سياقها كانت اولى الاليات التي
انشات في اطار منتدى التعاون العربي
الصيني منذ انطلاقه في عام 2004 وقد ساهمت
بشكل لافت في تعريف رواد الاعمال بفرص
الاستثمار المتاحه
وعقدت خلالها صفقات تجاريه واستثماريه
هامه اسهمت في تعزيز مسيره التنميه
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه في الدول العربيه
والصين كما تكتسب هذه الفعاليه اهميه
متزايده في ظل ما نشهده من تداعيات سلبيه
لتباطؤ النمو العالمي وازمه الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه وما نتج عنها من تاثيرات على
اسواق التكنولوجيا والمال
والغذاء
ونتطلع جميعا الى مناقشات ثريه في جلسات
هذا المؤتمر لاستشراف مستقبل الاستثمار
والاعمال
واستكشاف
السبل المثلى لتعظيم الاستفاده من الفرص
والامكانيات المتاحه الى الجانبين العربي
والصيني
حضور الكريم ان فرص الاستثمار في المنطقه
العربيه كثيره وواعده لكنها على النقيض من
ذلك ظلت مستقطبا ضعيفا لرؤوس الاموال رؤوس
الاموال الاجنبيه
الوارده اليها
بالمقارنه بمناطق جغرافيه اخرى حيث شهدت
الارقام المسجله تارجحا بين الصعود
والهبوط بسبب ما شهادته من احداث وازمات
وبالرغم من هذه المعطيات هناك مؤشرات
ايجابيه لتجاوز تلك العقبات في ظل ما
نرصده ما نرصده ما نرصده من خطط تنمويه
طموحه اطلقتها الدول العربيه كما يتيح
التعاون العربي الصيني فرصه ثمينه
لاستقطاب التكنولوجيا
ورؤوس الاموال والشركات الصينيه للاستثمار
في الدول العربيه لا سيما في اطار مبادره
الحزام والطريق ومبادره التنميه العالميه
اللتين اطلاقها فخامه الرئيس الصيني شيشنج
حضور الكريم وعلى صعيد العمل العربي
المشترك وكما تعلمون فقد اهتمت الجامعه
العربيه منذ عقود طويله بموضوع تحسين مناخ
الاستثمار العربي وخلق فضائل اقتصادي
عربيه موحد فضلا عن جهودها لبناء شركات مع
التجمعات الاقتصاديه
الاقليميه والدوليه ومنها هذا المنتدى
واكتفي هنا بالاشاره الى امرين على سبيل
المثال
تعلق الاول اعتماد الدول العربيه
الاتفاقيه الموحده لاستثمار رؤوس الاموال
في الدول العربيه
والتي يجري الان اعداد المسوده الجديده
لها بالتعاون مع مؤسسه دوليه ذات خبره
كبيره في هذا المجال
واغتنموا هذه الفرصه لاشكر وزاره
الاستثمار السعوديه التي قدمت للامانه
العامه لل العربيه مساهمه مشاهدين كنا
معكم في متابعه لفعاليات مؤتمر الاعمال
العربي الصيني في الرياض ومتابع ايضا
لكلمه الامين العام لجامعه الدول العربيه
احمد ابو الغيط انتهت هذه النشره
المشاهدين ونتابع معكم المزيد في سياق
النشاط المقبله شكرا لحسن المتابعه وفي
امان الله
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات